this is Jonathan Ferguson the keeper of
firearms and artillery at the Royal
armies Museum in the UK which houses a
collection of thousands of iconic
weapons from throughout history and this
week as he also moonlights as an expert
of vampire law he's taking a look at the
weapons of redfall so a whole class of
weapons that are stake launchers I
approve of that in principle uh for it
for a vampire game that makes a lot of
sense in reality if you were trying to
launch Stakes I suspect 12 gauge shotgun
would probably be the best platform to
start with but hey I'm not a vampire
hunter make sure to subscribe and let us
know what other games or guns you'd like
to start with a breakdown in the
comments section below right let's take
a look at the guns of redfall
right this is a bit of a mystery so I
was initially presented with something
that looked plausibly like a you know
Factory produced 20th century handgun of
some kind but doesn't really match
anything that I can think of um there's
a Chinese pistol a qus said 92 I think
it is that is close except for the the
well except for all details
um and the protruding Barrel at the
front that's relatively unusual the only
reason to have a barrel protruding that
far from a slide conventional length
slide obviously you have the P38
famously with exposed Barrel but that's
because it has a short slide you
wouldn't normally have Barrel protruding
out Beyond a full length slide there's
no reason for it a short extended barrel
threaded for a suppressor would be the
the only real reason to do that so
that's a slightly curious design feature
overall the design is plausible and I
think it's been referenced from real
life Firearms just based on how sort of
plausible it does look already a curious
design but fair enough you design your
own guns for your fictional reality
that's fine but then we've got the same
gun still under the name centipede but
it's not the same gun has a different
different slide different frame
different trigger with a big exposed
coil spring behind it that almost
implies some sort of craft produced
design as does the shape of the slide as
well and then a very strange muzzle
device that looks a bit like a machine
gun booster kind of with with holes in
it I'm not sure what that's supposed to
do but I'm not sure it would do very
much in real life very strange kind of
suppressor height sights that look like
they were made in a shed I'm reading
this correctly is that we've got the
original centipede that was made in a
factory and someone has made their own
version of it or having said all of that
the the frame looks more like a beat up
factory made frame just of a different
design so this is pretty bewildering
right out the gate just with the pistol
from this game so we'll move on
so pretty well I say straightforward
shotgun not necessarily there's a lever
Loop under the action and a top brake
lever as well which is sitting very
proud of the stock slightly curious
design there but on the face of it it's
a side-by-side break action shotgun I
just wanted to comment on the stake so
clearly we have to use Stakes to kill
vampires this has been attached offset
with some sort of clamps looks a little
bit like Leverage on that would be a
problem
um the steak looks quite thin and
breakable it's very very pointy which I
guess it would have to be to do the job
but I don't know how many stakings you'd
get before the point would become blunt
from Impact or snap off but here we need
a pointer stick and so it's okay fair
enough it's on the um on the shotgun
giving you a bit more length as well
because this is a very short gun and
like a spear like a pike like a rifle
with a Bayonet you need some reach to be
able to especially if this thing is a
supernatural Beast with Talons you want
to keep them at a distance so I'm happy
enough with the with the overall design
as an anti-vampire weapon I do Moonlight
as
um uh vampire and zombie specialist when
it comes to arms and armor for my sins
now uh I don't have it here today
because it's on display for the public
but I did acquire for us some years ago
a vampire killing kit and I do the air
quotes because I'm at pains to point out
that these things were not conceived and
made as far as we know in the 19th
century these are probably invented in
the 1970s could be as far back as the
early 20th century but there's no real
evidence for that there I still think
they're very cool and I was persuaded
actually to acquire a real one so we
have a real vampire killing kit and it's
very popular and it's an important piece
of popular culture our vampire killing
kit the stakes are too short because
it's a nice portable box and a nice
thing to look at and have here we have
something that's ostensibly for actually
staking a vampire in the hearts now the
actual staking in the game it seems like
it a lot of the work's done for you it
would have been cool to have to have a
bit of precision over hitting the heart
traditionally you stake the heart to
kill the vampire but it does seem like
it's essentially the same as Call of
Duty bayonet press the button kills the
thing
down
so something I do appreciate is
attention to to law uh lore of course
with vampire stuff being something of an
Aficionado these of these things myself
uh folklore and fiction so wooden Stakes
obviously and then fire damage so it's
not uncommon for vampires and games to
be especially vulnerable to to fire
damage from fire
um and that's somewhat traditional in
the fiction and in the folklore
interestingly enough it was kind of the
ultimate disposal method for a body
suspected of being vampires or revenants
if they tried everything else they would
eventually
um try to burn the corpse to nothing
because the corpse is nothing corpse
can't harm you so this this all stems
back to or comes back to I won't say
reality but what people believed was was
reality so what's the best way to
deliver fire damage well maybe not the
best way but the best convenient way in
a sort of vaguely real world scenario a
flare pistol and so we have two flare
pistols standard looking Single Barrel
thing looks quite chunky and metallic
like it might be a military style one
the double barrel flare gun though is a
bit more interesting that is the Liga
pistola L model
and it's not bang on to the game model
but it's clearly where the inspiration
came from and it has the
leave out in front of the trigger guard
to leave her open the double barrels
insert your cartridges there's a shotgun
style extractor there and we've also got
the selector lever on the back that's
represented on the model here as well
because what we're not only opening the
gun with this lever that's why it has so
much effort behind it we are all so
cocking the gun that puts it
automatically on safe as well good idea
and you can see we have two pins
protruding on the back here to indicate
both Strikers are cocked that means
in the middle position both fire and I
can then select they're labeled L and R
which is um amusing in a way so left
only fires the left and so on quite
quite a cool historical firearm it's not
a weapon per se
I've got a revolver here in a couple of
different configurations it's
generically sort of Smith and Wesson
Taurus I have a short barrel Taurus here
that's somewhat Akin not exactly spot on
by any means I don't again like the
other weapons in the game I don't think
it's a direct base off anything else
there are design features from different
guns on it one set of grips on it though
was very reminiscent of the Ruger series
with that inset panel so black grips
with an inset colored panel so that's
possibly where that design cue has come
from the way the the rear sights set
into the the frame on the top is quite
distinctive generically it's a it's a
push latch Smith western style system in
this case it's a Taurus
yeah
so a whole class of weapons that are
stake launchers I approved of that in
principle uh for a vampire game it makes
a lot of sense gives you some artistic
license as well to move away from the
just a firearm thing in reality if you
were trying to launch Stakes I suspect
12 gauge shotgun would probably be the
best platform to start with but hey I'm
not a vampire hunter I don't know why
these have rotating barrels this this
thing's hugely bulky anyway so you're
not saving anything by rotating each
shot into alignment with whatever's
being used to propel it like you like
you are in a revolver where you're
having to align the cartridge with the
barrel each time lots of reasons to have
rotating barrels I don't think these
things have them you might have a
rotating striker to fire if indeed it's
using cartridges to propel those the
stakes which it doesn't look like it is
I'm going to try and figure out what's
propelling the stakes there are some
massive Springs on show so I suspect
that might be it we've also got breach
loading which is interesting I'm not
sure again and that you're achieving
much by loading the barrel slash rail
thing from the back you can just as
easily shove them in the front I would
think like a spear gun which I guess
would be the other way to try to kill a
vampire with a length of wood I do like
the sort of improvised sharpened lengths
of wood that are being used propelling
these things into a brick wall is
problematic to say the least wood
doesn't have much mass and is not very
hard so you need a heck of a lot of
force to push it through something dense
like brick
blood suckers are gone so ultraviolet so
that this is um other than sunlight
spoiler alert Nosferatu gets evaporated
by the Sun at the end of that the 1922
film uh which is pretty much where
sunlight as a weapon is what it is where
it's first introduced and that was
extrapolated into ultraviolet weapons in
well certainly by the early 2000s so
it's normally just a lamp UV lamp just
like you you could rig one up now and it
would work and I like that about the UV
weapon as it's harnessing the power of
this supposedly ancient means of
annoying vampires with simple technology
and it's just a beam of light this is a
little bit of a halfway house so it's
essentially a beam of light and it
freezes them it well petrifies them
solid uh almost more like an ice weapon
in video game terms in that respect and
then you can destroy them by shooting
them sort of shortcutting the whole
staking or fire thing so indirectly the
UV has killed them but not directly
riffing on the whole vampire thing and
and how weapons might be able to kill
them in a in a somewhat different way so
I'm I'm quite pleased with that the
weapon itself seems a bit like Overkill
um it's it's looks like a
purpose-designed weapon rather than just
a UV lamp but it doesn't have you know
it's not like the weaponized UV in some
of the the movies where it's actually
burning enough to just kill them where
they stand it's turning them to stay
essentially
okay we have a bit of a visual gag here
uh the weapon is called a grave mistake
I'm assuming this is some sort of
prestige version of another weapon that
I haven't seen yet and it is looks like
an M14 buried under buried sorry pun not
intended under a load of Bones there's a
skull on the end with the flash highness
sticking out of its eye socket and
there's a femur protruding from the
mouth which is clearly meant to operate
as a stake but why would bone steak a
vampire and it's a rather it's it's
almost it's a bit existence with its um
sort of body Horror oh and some random
ropes I guess you'd need the ropes to
hold the bones on a bit of a strange one
but quite metal so we'll allow it
all right the Famas as as well as the
slightly gaudy color scheme stickers on
this thing you'll probably notice the
magazine is curved so that would tend to
indicate the G2 variant on this one we
have the original 25 round straight
French magazine which is more typical or
is typical of the F1 variant of the mass
but we do have some quite a lot of
features there that are correct the
general shape the iconic carry handle
with the charging handle inside in fact
Fair bit of detail the more I look at it
the more detail I see the bipod legs you
saw me fold up the ribbed barrel for
this adjustable grenade launcher
allowing for different distances
depending on where it's set that's what
that does in case you've ever wondered
this has been fairly closely based given
the somewhat cartoony art style of the
game on a real famous but there are a
number of departure points um I won't
labor now it says here ball pup
automatic assault rifle okay ballpark we
know what that means broadly speaking
working parts behind the grip automatic
assault rifle is a redundant term the
term assault rifle questionably useful
though it is implies automatic fire
capability by default so uh calling an
automatic assault rifle is pointless all
right so it appears that the famous
bayonet is capable of killing vampires
which makes no sense at all mechanically
like game game won't play wise uh it's
clearly because they want it to look
like a famous bayonet or a military
rifle bayonet but to still have the
effect of the state but much like the
leg the sharpened leg bone wouldn't kill
the vampire I'd neither would a bayonet
otherwise what's the point in having
wooden Stakes bayonet is better in every
way than a wooden stake literally the
only reason to use a wooden stake is the
folklore idea that the wood is somehow
critical to the wounding mechanism so it
kind of undermines their own premise
here by allowing even if it's only
cosmetic on one level a bayonet blade to
act just like a wooden stake I'm not
wild about that
[Applause]
uh the dreaded arms or striker or
protector or whatever it is we've shown
it before on the series actually quite a
close representation underneath all of
these bits and Bobs and jaw bones and
whatever is on there I've seen the base
model and it's it's quite close to the
real thing the loading as well um insert
round wind insert round that's basically
how it works as well and they're showing
the ejector Rod being used as well so
maybe a bit more attention to the
reality of this weapon than some of the
others if I can say that but then of
course we've covered it full of weird
metal strips and bones and Weld and it
certainly looks interesting I'm not sure
what all of that gives you
thanks for watching everyone those were
the guns of redfall as always if you'd
like to check out what we do here at the
Royal armories Museum you can come and
visit one of our three sites or head
over to our website our social media
platforms especially our own YouTube
channel where you'll see me talking more
nonsense about guns in any case we'll
see you again next time